what does having a california christmas
reaching number one on netflix mean to
you
that's an interesting interesting
question that i have
i have actually wrestled with because
it was absolutely unexpected and i i
really really was in shock and
and i was gratified and i was grateful
and i was so happy to be part of
that special holiday season for people
and i was so happy to hear how much they
enjoyed it
um i've had a lot of success
in my life and i've always kind of had
this illusion that that would be
a turning point you know where i would
have this big moment
and and
things would would evolve in just this
amazingly
positive and prosperous way you know
like
when i won the vma for moby or when
britney blew up or you know when
county was in theaters you know i've had
these moments
and and invariably you know i've not
had the expected results and i've i feel
like i've been disappointed
um and i always kind of you know felt
like oh this is my moment to level up
you know
and um i mean obviously i have leveled
up because you know i'm doing cooler
stuff now than i was then but
but you know we all have ambitions to be
beyond where we are
and and i've just never fulfilled my
hope for that
and um so when when the
movie came out a lot of people were
conflating its success with mine
and they were saying oh you must be so
happy you're going to do so well you're
so lucky
and i'm thinking well first of all i
have no profit participation in this
movie
i got a flat salary and i will never see
another penny from it um but the other
thing is i
really i got to the point where i got
like really uncomfortable like
really emotionally uncomfortable and i
was thinking that you know what this is
is that i just i am a very humble person
and i'm uncomfortable with compliments
and attention and the spotlight
you know but i'm still going to be
grateful and appreciative
you know i used to i had i had this
girlfriend once because i was
uncomfortable with compliments tell me
you know just shut up and let them say
nice things you know and let
let them feel good don't don't you know
because i'd be like oh no it's not true
and it's like well she said that's not
polite that's not nice
but anyway so i let them have their
moment but this dissonance
really bothered me and and then i i kind
of realized later on
that that i was in my mind i was like i
i can't get my expectations up with this
hyperbole
you know this overwhelming hyperbole
from all these people
because you know to hear them say it
it's
you know you know going to be all
sunshine and rainbows and
you know limousines and award shows and
i'm just like that's probably not going
to happen and i
i can't let myself buy into that because
because it's
it's it's
the come down is really hurtful and and
the higher
the expectation the worse the come down
now i'm not saying good things aren't
going to happen i mean good things
already have happened you know
but but but what i don't want is that is
to get my head so up in the clouds
um because those good things will happen
regardless of
of my expectation for them
um and i just don't want to have that
disappointment i would rather be
pleasantly surprised by oh that's nice
you know than than thinking and hoping
and and then it's just not realized so
it was it was a it was a complicated
experience and
and i tried to always be present to be
grateful
and appreciate the moment and um
somebody said to me well it was a shame
you couldn't enjoy that and i said
i said well i did in the sense that you
know
again i consider myself an artist and i
created something nice
and people appreciated it and and that's
enough
you know i just have to know that that's
enough that's you know
just like i told you earlier what was my
contract with myself my contract
was that i would be an artist and
anything beyond that is a bonus
and and if i remind myself of that and i
keep myself
grounded in that and i know that people
appreciate it and and i look at that
enthusiasm and hyperbole
as an expression of their
experience then then it's it's very it's
still gratifying i'm
i'm humbled i'm glad i mean it's you
know we don't all our projects don't
mean that much to people and it's nice
you know i mean it's nice if i create
something and it's meaningful to me
you know like those those guys who did
all those bugs bunny
cartoons you know the chuck jones he
said
um you know we weren't trying to make
them for kids you know we made them for
ourselves
and they found an audience on saturday
mornings and people thought they were
kids shows
you know and same thing with this i mean
when i'm behind the camera
i'm i'm not thinking about you or those
netflix viewers i'm like
what do i like and what make what i
think is pretty and
and i believe that the director and the
producers and netflix
you know are trusting my aesthetic
because i've demonstrated it
and and so i'm just doing that aesthetic
i mean if somebody specifically said oh
i want a hair light
or i want this shadow i would create
that but one of the things i do take as
a compliment
is is i very seldom have people tell me
to change stuff
you know i just do what i want i do what
feels right and then they're happy um
so that's that's you know my experience
with
the movie maybe a little more
complicated than you were expecting
no it's really interesting you know
someone once told me this advice
in relation to something similar what
goes up must come down and i never and
it was so weird because i was literally
thinking about that last night so maybe
i was
i don't know it's just weird but there's
a lot to that and that's not to negate
good things happening but knowing that
at some point
it will come down and to not be
devastated by that well and the higher
you
go the further you have to fall
i really was cognizant of that i was
like oh my god you know this
is huge and if i write it it's oh my god
i'm just gonna
be shattered
[Laughter]
so i just i didn't emotionally again i
just i reconnected with the reason i did
it i didn't
i didn't do it for accolades i mean it
would be nice strategically if
if somebody wants to hire me for
something and i get some really cool
jobs and clients because again that's
just more creative gratification and
working with cool people and doing
nice things that hopefully people will
enjoy you know
but it's a it's a means to an end the
the the
adulation in and of itself is
uncomfortable
to me how did you find out that the film
was number one on netflix
i think sean texted me the director um
it was either that or i saw a facebook
or an instagram post but i
i'm pretty sure he texted me we were all
in shock
look we knew it was a fun little movie
but it was a little movie it was a
little
you know cute little thing that we did
and it's all of us have been involved in
stuff that going into it seemed like a
bigger project if that makes sense you
know we just thought this was a little
bitty
sweet christmas movie um and you know
the fact that it just
i mean my god it was number one in the
world for eight days
i was looking at individual countries i
had
friends in france and the philippines
and canada and um
england and wales and
colombia and and brazil and they're like
oh my god we saw your movie we love your
movie i'm just like oh
wow you know i've never had that i've
never had a simultaneous global release
ever never um i mean maybe those music
videos but that was
15 years ago and the internet didn't
exist in the same way it does now
it's just it's just oh my god i just
like all these people
talking about it and loving it and
wishing me well
and i mean somebody in the philippines
somebody in russia is watching my movie
and and um and they're liking it and
it's like
well you know you can't you really can't
hope for more than that
i mean i was looking at those those
charts
and we were above both grinch movies we
were above jim carrey we were above the
animated grinch movie
we were above like literally all this
other stuff
when i looked at the at the rate
rankings
california christmas was number 13
for the entire year of 2020 over
all other genres of movies and that's
only more incredible when you consider
it was only in release for two weeks
a 26th of the year
and it was number 13. our little teeny
tiny movie
over all the george clooney's and
jennifer aniston's and
you know wow you know that's cool and
i'm glad i'm
again i more than more than getting full
of myself
i'm glad people enjoyed it i'm glad that
it was a part of their christmas
especially
now when so many people are having a
hard time i'm glad
that it was a distraction i'm glad it
made them smile
you